this is our universe an ever expanding
network of stars and galaxies
and this is your brain
um don't they look eerily similar to one
another
why are they so alike
could your brain be a mini version of
the cosmos
or could the universe actually be part
of some larger consciousness
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the universe is conscious
your brain is made up of neurons these
are cells that process information and
signals throughout your body
between these neurons is an underlying
network of connections that allows them
to communicate with each other
and on the largest scale imaginable the
galaxies in our universe form clusters
with vast amounts of empty space in
between
these clusters are connected to each
other by a complex Network known as
Cosmic webs
the universe and your brain
puzzling isn't it well maybe our
universe is a lot more complex than we
thought
it might just be some sort of giant
brain
digging into these Concepts can be
challenging and sometimes I need help
breaking things down so that I can
understand them better well that's why I
use blinkist blinkist is an app that
allows you to understand the most
critical ideas from over 5500
non-fiction books and podcasts in an
exceptional audio experience in just 15
minutes you can listen to powerful
insights into mind-blowing topics from
over 27 categories right now I'm
checking out Futures with Robert Mason
it Dives deep into the developments that
might drastically alter what it means to
be human
and with the new blinkist connect
feature you can share a subscription
with a premium account so when you're
reading about the mysteries of the
universe or unique marketing strategies
well you can share these insights with
your best friend that's two Premium
Accounts for the price of one so let's
find new Inspirations together get a
seven day free trial at blinkist.com
what if sign up now and get 25 off if
you're lucky maybe the universe will
share its subscription with you
now you could be thinking wow what if
has really gone off the rails with this
episode this guy's crazy but we're not
the only ones to notice the similarities
between galaxies and the cosmos and
neurons in the human brain
astrophysicists and neurosurgeons have
been studying these networks and they've
found that the cosmos looks very similar
to your brain just on a much larger
scale
your brain is 77 water and the cosmic
web is about 73 dark energy
there are around 69 billion neurons in
your brain and the cosmic web could
connect at least 100 billion galaxies
not exactly the same but not too far off
either
wait there's more
neurons and galaxies both share a
similar pattern
two and a half millimeters of your brain
looks like 500 million light years of
space
pretty cool right well even that isn't
all each neuron of that two and a half
millimeters of your brain connects to
about five other neurons
and in space each galaxy has about four
different connections
your brain and the cosmos aren't
identical but they are similar enough
for you to ask this
is the universe a giant brain
[Music]
could it have its own consciousness
theoretically the universe could achieve
Consciousness but only if it managed to
understand its position in space and
time
then it would need to understand how it
relates to other things like you
have I blown your mind yet
now the universe isn't exactly like your
brain it's a lot harder for it to
exchange information between the
galaxies
it might be conscious but on a level we
don't yet understand
and how could we understand the
consciousness of our universe if we
don't even fully know what Consciousness
is and how it works
what we do know is that your own
Consciousness is pretty Advanced all
thanks to your ability to understand
what the future is
humans are one of the few animals that
think about tomorrow
yeah at least as far as We Know
but maybe we over complicate things
maybe Consciousness isn't an intricate
biological thing only humans have
maybe Consciousness is when systems
relate to each other and work together
like the universe
then yes the universe is conscious
especially if you think of the universe
with its billions of galaxies billions
upon billions of star systems
planets
moons
that's a lot of consciousness
maybe there are other universes living
on a much larger scale communicating
with each other like we do
and maybe they collide
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]